vous venez me voir pour la première fois
la donne on désire époux mariés oui
l' agence matrimoniale le lieu pour
rencontrer celui ou celle avec qui
partager toute une vie elles marquent
leur grand retour aujourd'hui elles qui
avaient connu leur heure de gloire dans
les années 60 et 70
kandia pas l' agence matrimoniale
chercher la voiture ça non pas de
l'histoire sérieuse à une époque où il
n'y avait ni appelé ni site de
rencontres dans les années 70 plus de
1000 agences matrimoniales joue les
marieuses en france avec des clients de
tous âges et de toutes catégories
sociales étudiantes en lettres
cette journaliste j'ai cru bien faire de
vous présenter elles ont leurs petites
recettes pour rapprocher deux
célibataires
le flair de l'agent matrimoniale bien
sûr mais déjà en 1965
bien avant les algorithmes d'aujourd'hui
des méthodes très pointu âge poids
taille profil psychologique critères
recherchés tout est codé dans ses fiches
perforé une sorte de carte d'identité
amoureuse vous prenez la carte perforée
de mademoiselle duval et celle de
monsieur durand ou les juxtaposer et si
à la lecture par transparence vous voyez
apparaître beaucoup de points lumineux
c'est que mademoiselle du valais
monsieur durand sont faits l'un pour
l'eau les agences se perfectionne dans
les années 70 et les analyses les goûts
les hobbies les pratiques sexuelles et
parfois des petits trucs en plus comme
ici le test psychologique de l'arbre
s'étendre là à ce qui frappe d'abord
c'est son aspect tourmenté souffrent
douloureux coucher
toutes les méthodes sont bonnes à
prendre car il faut afficher des
résultats pour appâter de nouveaux
clients dans les années 70 n'est patron
d'aj ans se vante d'être à l'origine de
plusieurs centaines de mariages chaque
année ça fait donc trois ans vous êtes
mariés
si je vous demande si vous êtes heureux
qu est ce que vous préparez les
blessures donc vous conseiller aux gens
qui sont en tout cas qui va le temps
qu'ils n'ont pas de relation de
s'adresser une agence ya pas de problème
alors la bonne taille
pas de problème enfin robin vous savez
un m'as promis monts et merveilles mais
ya trois ans que ça dure je cours comme
une arme j'ai perdu on a promis le
présentation par semaine j'attends
toujours
il ya de quoi être exigeant car tout ça
c'est un budget entre 500 et 1500 francs
pour une année d'adhésion dans les
années 70 et aujourd'hui les agences
existent toujours compter entre 1000 et
15000 euros l'année d'adhésion depuis
quelques années elles font de la
résistance face aux applis de rencontre
des sites de rencontres virtuelles sont
pour moi plus une bergerie dans laquelle
il y a beaucoup de loup puisque dans une
agence matrimoniale la sécurité le
sérieux voilà le secret de longévité des
agences matrimoniales dans la course au
match
[Musique]